okay I'm happy to open the conference on
US policy in the Middle East this
conference was co-organized by Arnold
Saltzman Institute for wall in peace and
the begins to that Center for satiric
studies at bar-ilan University in Israel
I have been involved in organizing many
conferences and I had the relations with
a variety of academics and I'm totally
happy to say that this one was one of
the easiest a professor which I'll bet
and professor was too long were great
partners we had a very amicable
relationship and anybody that knows
academic life should appreciate it at
this stage we have to acknowledge the
support for this conference of the
Dougherty and Harold Greene world
foundation in Hebrew we have a proverb a
man came up in TOA it translates rather
well in into English a without door
there is no learning I hope that all of
us
come out of here with a bit more
knowledge about the relationship between
cited state in the Middle East this is a
very important subject hey and I will
confess that I'm not Catholic in any way
many things that you know we have a lot
of power in the world but visa was not
involved in organizing the turmoil in
the Middle East in order to generate
greater interest in the conference so
it's my pleasure now to call upon
professor Bates and the host here at
Columbia and to welcome you professor
Bates well behalf of the Arnold a
Saltzman Institute of war and peace
studies I welcome you today of
reflection commentary and exchange of
ideas on US policy in the Middle East
corsten's region was at the top of the
American agenda when Professor Anbar
proposed this conference some months ago
and recent dramatic events have only
accentuated that importance I want to
thank professor in bar and the vague and
Sadat center and the Greenwald
foundation for making the conference
possible of course we can't explore the
full range of Middle East issues in
detail today we'll focus on to general
sets of high priority problems the Arab
Israel conflict and the Persian Gulf and
how the United States can deal with them
the individual speakers today have their
own views and can argue them with
conviction of course the University and
seba and the Saltzman Institute don't
have institutional positions on foreign
policy issues and make no assumptions
about the validity of any policy
judgments will hear today we have a jam
packed agenda so I'm not going to waste
any more time blessing this event I'll
only say that I will try to keep the
panelists on time in order to leave time
for audience questions and we'll keep
the breaks between sessions shorter than
the norm for conferences
I hope you look forward as I do to as
wide as possible a discussion with no
thoughtful arguments or points of view
at about Thank You professor bit say I
would like to call upon and my colleague
professor a tangle ba is professor of
political studies at bar-ilan University
and he also has an appointment at the
University of Southern California and he
would speak about obama and the Israeli
political conflict Israeli Alan good
morning thank you very much I'll devote
my presentation to the view from
Jerusalem about Obama's policy in the
Middle East in particular toward the are
busily conflict in the context of the
dramatic recent events of violence and
revolt a guy against existing regimes in
the Middle East I want to say from the
beginning that both Israel and the
United States are facing very serious
and difficult challenges and the problem
is that they aren't good options to deal
with them nobody knows how and when the
present violence and events and and when
and how they will end but several
treatment preliminary lessons or
emerging what is happening now um I'll
make a few statements about Obama's
policy towards the arab-israeli conflict
first it's now almost obvious that the
israeli-palestinian and the israeli-arab
conflict or not the most important issue
in the Middle East Iran's missions
authoritarian regimes and Islamic
fundamentalism or much more
it's not the main source of instability
if there are any linkages between the
ARB israeli conflict and all other
problems in the Middle East they won and
move exactly in the opposite direction
of what has been suggested by the United
States in recent years the United States
approach to the recent turmoil has been
confusing and inconsistent to too many
peoples and observers in the Middle East
to both allies and rivals alike too many
leaders in the Middle East are asking
what the United States really want to
achieve in the present in the present
stage the United States this is how it's
being viewed from Israel United States
confuses democratic processes with
democracy voting is not democracy voting
perhaps should be the last step in a
democratic process and a democratic
process can lead to different types of
dictatorships worse than the one that it
it replaces and it seems that the United
States standing in the middle east is on
the on the decline there are many
questions about US leadership and
reliability especially in times of
crisis and upheaval I'd like to spend a
few minutes about specific issues press
issue is the palestinian-israeli
negotiations Israel and the Palestinians
have not been able to resume
negotiations terminated at the end of
the Bush administration it seems that
there are a number of reasons for it the
settlement issue is not one of them from
Jerusalem it looks like the excessive
emphasis by the Obama administration on
settlements and the heavy pressure
on Israel backfired Prime Minister
Netanyahu in fact accepted two of the
two major demands or requests from the
Obama administration he declared he
support for the two-state solution and
he also declared freezing of settlements
for about 10 month Obama asked other
Arab countries to take similar measures
of confidence measure none responded in
fact nothing I was the only one to
accept these requests we know that the
settlement issue is not has not been the
main obstacle to peace because there was
a freeze for 10 month still the
Palestinians did not come to the table
in the last month they finally agreed to
some indirect negotiations it seems that
there are more serious impediments to
negotiations which perhaps have been
underestimated by the Obama
administration basically I thank the
israeli-palestinian conflict is not ripe
for resolution this is a term taken from
accomplished resolution theories the
levels of concessions that the two sides
are ready to give each other are
insufficient to to reach a comprehensive
peace agreement we know that already
from the Olmert government negotiations
with Mahmoud Abbas it seems that the
maximum that Israel is prepared to give
does not meet the minimum that
Palestinians or demanding there are the
problem serious problems such as very
weak Palestinian leadership there's not
a kind of leadership that could be
expected to make those major concessions
needed to reach a peaceful peaceful
agreement there's this split between
Hamas and and the Palestinians where
Hamas is really holding a veto power
because even if the Palestinian
Authority in Israel reached an agreement
and
they can fire missiles and undermine the
whole thing and it seems that a
Palestinian strategy in in recent month
has been to avoid negotiations to delete
itemized Israel both inside and outside
especially in international forums and
to obtain recognition from as many
states as possible and from the United
Nations in a Palestinian state within
the nineteen sixty-seven borders second
issue which I want to talk about is
linkage between resolution of the
israeli-palestinian conflict and an ear
on the Obama administration claimed time
and again that it needs a resolution of
the israeli-palestinian conflict in
order to create a coalition in the
Middle East or fair Arab allies of the
United States to prevent Iran from
acquiring nuclear weapons from the
beginning this claim has been suspicious
because it assumes that the Arab states
have no interest of their own in
containing Iran and that they would
rather subjugate their own interest to a
policy to the Palestinian interest which
has never been the case but WikiLeaks
documents have shown that Arab countries
allies of the United States exerted
pressure on the United States to take
much tougher positions toward Iran they
did not need resolution of the
israeli-palestinian conflict the next
issue which i want briefly to touch upon
is the facts of the of the current
crisis on the arab-israeli conflict here
we have a debate inside Israel the left
argues that this is another opportunity
to resume negotiations and to reach an
agreement not only with the Palestinians
but also with the entire Arab world the
this argument is based on the assumption
that Arab leaders would be more willing
now to help these negotiations they left
also argues that
if indeed the Palestinian strategy were
to succeed that Israel would find itself
in a very difficult and isolated
position in the world the right on the
end on the other hand argues that that
the position or the effects should point
to a very different directions first of
all we see that there are some questions
ap out about peace agreements in the two
countries that have signed peace
agreement with Israel Egypt and Jordan
this is with peace with Israel is not
popular in the Arab world and oddly
enough intellectuals the Liberals have
been against the peace and the
translation of the peace agreements into
people-to-people peace which we which we
call in professional terms room peace
peace but not not only between leaders
but also between between peoples and and
so this is the case the question is what
Arab leaders under pressure now would
benefit or gain from from participating
in new efforts to reach comprehensive
peace agreements between Israel and its
Arab neighbors the right also argues
that what we what would be the value of
agreement sign now with leaders whom you
don't know if can survive the present
phase of turmoil what if you were to
sign an agreement with Bashar Assad in
Syria what will be the fate of such web
suction of such an agreement so we see
this debate between left and right but
this is not you in Israeli politics
there have been always very very heated
debates about what Israel should do in a
particular phase one one place or
another I think then that the chances
for resumed negotiations between Israel
students will have to wait until we see
where the developments in the Middle
East will take us and what will be the
United States standing in the world and
in the Middle East following those
events and I be happy to answer
questions a bit later thank you thank
you hey I would like to call upon
Professor William quant professor Qantas
a old hand in Middle Eastern affairs his
professor at the University of Virginia
he served among other things as a staff
member on the National Security Council
and he would speak about Obama's
dilemmas in the arab-israeli conflict
thank you very much thank you for having
me today i'll start by saying that I
essentially agree with previous speaker
that if you came hoping to hear good
news about the imminent revival of
something that we used to call the peace
process I'm not going to be the one who
steers you in that direction this is a
time when I think most of us look at the
Middle East and see many other things
that are commanding people's attention
but one of them is not right now the
arab-israeli peace possibilities
nonetheless I want to talk a little bit
about how this administration and
generally how American ministrations
typically have approached the
arab-israeli component of the various
Middle East challenges that they face
because I think there are some general
propositions here and there are some
very distinctive things about how Obama
himself has tried to engage and now
seems to be stepping back a bit I think
I would start by saying that the
arab-israeli conflict whatever a
president and his or her we haven't had
to her yet but his advisers may think
has a way of capturing their attention
more than they perhaps would like it's
the kind of issue that because of its
domestic resonance
sensitivity in the international
community cannot be easily delegated to
a Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
for Near Eastern affairs this is an
issue that comes up to the presidential
level repeatedly and so presidents have
to think through how they want to
approach it the other point I would make
in a very general sense is that the
arab-israeli issue is always part of a
larger regional picture and sometimes
people make connections the so-called
linkage issue sometimes they try to
isolate the arab-israeli issue and say
well it doesn't really have much to do
with what's happening in the Gulf or the
democratization movements in the Middle
East but you have to think about the
region as a whole and within that region
there is this issue of Israel Palestine
arab-israeli conflict that that has to
be assessed as part of a kind of
regional approach and right and
sometimes the regional issues become so
much more intense such as the Iranian
Revolution in 1979 that they compete
with or overshadow attempts to focus on
the arab-israeli issue when I was in
government in the Carter Administration
my colleague Gary sick and I were both
we worked in a little two-person office
on the National Security Council staff
and I was doing arab-israeli things
while he was doing Iran and in 1978 that
was a real challenge because I kept
saying my issues more import I was doing
the egyptian-israeli stuff my issues are
more important and it was pretty clear
that his issues were pretty important
and we only had one president who could
only add so many hours in the day to pay
attention and that is also a reality the
issues sometimes compete with one
another and right now we have other
issues that are obviously vying for top
priority now various American
politicians and presidents have thought
about the arab-israeli conflict in
different ways some have thought that
this is a conflict that to use professor
gobos words is not ripe for resolution
have some problems of that as a concept
but it's nonetheless truth a lot of
people have told themselves that and so
therefore they think the proper approach
is one of trying to manage or contain
the conflict since it's not ready to be
resolved you just want to try to do what
you can to keep it from exploding and by
and large that was the approach of
American administrations from about 1952
about 1973 with maybe a few exceptions
and then there are moments when we think
the issue is so important that we need
to try to at least start the process of
trying to resolve all of it or part of
it or at least moderate the intensity of
it and i would say that from about
nineteen seventy three to two thousand
that was the dominant mindset of
successive presidents different degrees
of intensity but there was a view that
this is a problem that's important and
we need to try to lend our weight to the
resolution of the conflict in all or in
part particularly once the
egyptian-israeli part of it got got
moving in a fairly serious direction and
then that that effort kind of comes to
an end at the end of two thousand and
the Bush administration quite determined
Lee and nobody made the obligatory
announcement about cell phones but I
will remind you if you haven't turned
yours off please do from 2001 up until
up until two thousand eight nine we went
through a period when again other issues
in the Middle East trumped arab-israeli
peace diplomacy and we had a president
and some of his inner circle who simply
didn't think it was worth the time or
energy or that it was all all that
possible but they didn't buy the the
linkage argument and then Obama comes in
and Obama is an interesting case because
in many ways like we often see when
president from one party replaces a
successor from a different party there's
a tendency to say I'm going to do things
very differently in foreign policy
across the board
in in the Middle East that meant toward
Iraq and toward a lot of issues
including the Arabs early issue there
was an expectation that Obama would be
different and his language was kind of a
repeat of the language that you would
have found in this period that I
referred to as in the kind of 1970s 80s
and 90s the Clinton years of the United
States is going to try to help the
parties get back on track with
arab-israeli peace making his rationale
was a little bit different than previous
presidents he started he had sort of two
themes one was that the reputation of
the United States in the what he called
the Muslim world the Arab Islamic world
had taken a big hit which was true by
any normal set of measures partly
because of the Iraq war and partly
because of the perception over the
previous eight years or so that the
United States was stepping back from its
role of trying to broker in arab-israeli
peace and that part of his strategy of
trying to restore the American image in
this part of the world was to show that
we were back in business leading
something called the peace process as
well as eventually getting out of Iraq
and so forth the other argument and it's
interesting that the president didn't
make it as much as some of his security
people did but you began to hear people
like David Petraeus and Bob gates say
that there's a strategic issue here when
the United States is at war in two
Muslim countries it is important for us
to be able to do all we can to resolve
the arab-israeli conflict and it will
make it easier for our troops to do
their job now whether that is true or
not as I'm not going to engage with
right now but it was interesting who was
making the security argument it was
people who had very little to do with
arab-israeli issues directly but who
were engaged in managing a war in Iraq
and managing Anna war in Afghanistan and
so there was a kind of sense that there
is a strategic
a reputational benefit if we can make
progress in arab-israeli peace making so
what happened with these good intentions
I think Obama wanted to try to push the
peace process forward first he was
caught by surprise by the Israeli
elections early in his tenure when
Benjamin Netanyahu became prime minister
I think that he expected that he would
be dealing with a Kadima lead government
he had been briefed on the Olmert Abu
Mazen talks by Condoleezza Rice and her
assessment is that they had gotten very
close and that therefore the Obama
administration should pick up where that
left off well there wasn't anything to
pick up and continue when not Netanyahu
first came in he did is we were reminded
convinced Netanyahu to affirm his
commitment to a two-state solution but
without any details of what that
two-state solution would look like and
the settlement freeze although it was
partial accomplishment was not complete
by any means so net on your mama tries
to use some degree of influence with
Netanyahu to so to show that he as
president is the stronger party
presidents tend to like to be taken
seriously and they like to show that
they have influenced the problem in this
case is that he took on an issue of
settlements that he was not able to see
through to a an impressive conclusion
that is when the dust finally settled
Netanyahu had made a partial concession
but not the full concession that the
President and Hillary Clinton had asked
for so Obama instead of looking strong
emerges toward the end of his first year
looking rather weak third problem that
he faced was the issue of weak
leadership weak leadership on
Palestinian side divided leadership
we've heard about that but also I think
week leadership on the Israeli side I
think Netanyahu has been very
good at resisting pressure he has not
been very good at forging a vision of
what piece might look like and I think
there are reasons for that he has a
cabinet that is divided over this and
perhaps an Israeli public that is as
well so when you have strong divisions
among the negotiating parties it's a
hard time to make peace there was
another problem on the American side and
this is kind of inside the beltway
considerations but the Obama team
dealing with the Middle East was
probably not optimally organized you had
at least four or five different voices
speaking out on what the policy was
George Mitchell you had Secretary of
State you had National Security Advisor
you had the President himself you have
the very valuable vice president and you
had Dennis Ross who originally was
supposed to be dealing with something
called the central region but pretty
quickly is back dealing with
arab-israeli issues so you had in some
ways too many voices and too little
coherence and that's a very typical but
self-inflicted kind of problem that the
president doesn't have to put up with
but they frequently do and then I think
there was a mistake made in the second
year when the moratorium on settlements
in the West Bank was beginning to come
to a hand and they started pressing very
very hard for negotiations as if
negotiations would somehow if you could
just get the Israelis and the
Palestinians to sit down together this
was going to miraculously unblock the
problem and of course negotiation sounds
like something you can't be against but
in this case the disparity between the
two parties is so great that unless
you've done a fair amount of preparatory
work just putting the parties in the
room together and expecting that they
will literally negotiate face-to-face
and resolve their problems is pretty
much wishful thinking you need some kind
of in my view
effective mediator to work between the
two parties in order to structure the
choices that each of them has so that as
they confront these truly existentially
difficult choices they not only
understand the concessions are going to
have to make but what they're going to
get out of it and if you just leave them
talking to each other I guarantee you
it's not going to work that way I think
as I watched the clock I have to drop a
couple of my other points but there was
also a kind of amateurish moment ok now
I don't want to take his minutes away
we'll have more discussion ok I'll take
him a few more minutes there was also I
think a rather amateurish moment when
you almost sort of sense that the the
Obama administration tour in the fall of
two thousand ten was beginning to get
very nervous that its approach to
getting negotiations started was was
falling apart wasn't working and they
tried desperately to get Netanyahu to
agree to a three-month extension of the
settlements freeze and you know you
think about it what how much value added
would there be you'd had ten months of a
settlement freeze what was supposed to
happen in the next three months and in
order to get that three-month settlement
freeze an enormous set of a number of
offers were made that seemed more than
than you would expect for the mere
three-month settlement freeze military
commitments economic commitments
virtually promise of an eventual
security treaty these are the kind of
big items that I would expect to be part
of a final peace agreement when israel's
making the truly difficult concessions
on territory and whatever else and then
you come in and say if you make those
concessions you can write whatever you
want into this chapter on what the US
security relationship will look this was
being offered for a three-month
extension of and i thought it was
amateur hour in spades I mean I couldn't
understand why you were playing such big
cards for such little gain and we still
got turned down that to me was a lesson
that the United States is losing its
cloud it's losing its cloud with Israel
we can't either bribe them or persuade
them simultaneously were losing our
cloud practically everywhere else in the
Middle East the Iranians weren't afraid
of what we were going to do if they
didn't negotiate a freeze on their
enrichment capabilities the Lebanese
despite a lot of pressure from the
United States went ahead and formed a
government with Hezbollah in it and then
government started coming up against
their own internal challenges including
pro-american regimes in Egypt and
elsewhere so I think I would argue that
the the results of this first two years
left the United States in the position
of less influence than we had had
probably at the outset of the Obama
administration new administration's tend
to be people take them seriously for a
while as they try to get their measure
but after two years we had not done very
well and we entered this period of the
so-called Arab Spring was kind of a nice
word for air upheavals and some of this
kind of feels like spring it looks
pretty good but some of it looks pretty
uncertain but it meant that we entered
that period with a fair amount of lack
of credibility that the United States
had a clear strategy so where does this
leave us now I think it leaves us on the
arab-israeli peace issues at an obvious
impasse there is no momentum there's no
party that has a strategy for breaking
the impasse and there are no obvious
openings although I think most at least
most people in my business and I speak
very much from an American analyst
standpoint if you said what would an
eventual israeli-palestinian agreement
look like what would an eventual Syrian
Israeli agreement look like we could
probably describe within
five or ten percent margin of difference
what we think it would look like if it
could be done at all there aren't a
whole lot of menus out there well you
could perhaps have this or this or this
if it's going to happen it's going to
look sort of like the Clinton parameters
the omar abu mazen with you know the
gaps bridge and on the Syrian front in
all honesty it is actually quite easy to
describe what it would look like just
you need to have a government in each
place that is ready to do it we are also
in the United States now approaching
that moment of paralysis called an
election year hasn't quite hit us yet
but you can begin to see I suspect those
of you who have come from Israel have
seen a few Republican candidates come to
visit that will continue and I suspect
even our president will if he's invited
which Enki has been make an appearance
before he faces the electorate in next
year and during that period he is not
going to take on an ambitious project if
it's going to be a controversial project
and in all honesty everything in
American politics now is controversial
if the president were to ask Congress to
pass legislation tomorrow saying that
motherhood is a good thing he would be
attacked for cheeping the notion of
motherhood in some quarters it is simply
impossible these days to do anything
without it becoming intensely
politicized so I think we're going to
have a period of drift we've had them
before sometimes they end dramatically
sometimes the end when we come to our
senses and realize that there is still
an issue called the arab-israeli
conflict it is still out there and it
still has important strategic
implications but I don't think it will
be in Obama's first term that he is
going to be able to do much about it
worthy to be reelected and working to
have a new team of advisers and were
there to be some new actors in the
region we might once again see something
called an american-led peace process
thank you
okay I would like to invite dr. Jonathan
vinyl he's a senior lecturer in
political studies at bar-ilan University
and senior associate at the business
center thank you f prime both our
previous speakers have to find
themselves as pessimists well I'd like
to be an optimist but an optimist
according to the Israeli definition and
an optimist according to the Israeli
definition of former cabinet minister
Yosef burgers goes like this I am an
optimist yesterday will be better than
tomorrow thank you when we think about
American policy towards the arab-israeli
conflict an American strategic interest
we've we think about conflict resolution
on one hand and conflict and conflict
management on the other hand what I want
to suggest is that actually what we have
is a sliding scale arrange a mix and
that one needs to find the right mix at
the right time if we look at the core
American strategic interest in the
Middle East what we see is number one
the protection of the flow of oil not
only to the United States but to the
world economy only one country can
guarantee militarily that supply and
that is the United States and we see the
goal of preventing the spread and the
use of weapons of mass destruction
combined with missiles and the
prevention of terrorism against the
United States and its allies and I think
it's pretty much widely accepted that in
order to protect that you need a
strategy which maintains a pro-american
balance of power in the Middle East and
some version of stability since in
effect the status quo of two months ago
is an American interest it may not be
great but it's perfectly acceptable the
question is where does the arab-israeli
peace process
in to this strategic picture how
important is it how does it affect
things now a common argument made
particularly against the Bush
administration was that if only the
arab-israeli conflict was resolved it
would be as it were a panacea for all
the strategic difficulties of the united
states in the region all the instability
in the region would dissolve
anti-americanism would decline
significantly and one might add the
messiah would also come and this then
put pressure to find a resolution to the
conflict and as we've already heard
there's a tendency in American foreign
policy on politics that when a president
of the opposite party comes in he says I
will do the opposite of the previous
President Bush jr. was anything but
Clinton Obama was anything but Bush jr.
and so this argument has been heavy in
the air recently what I want to suggest
is that recent events and the WikiLeaks
suggest that this is very much mistaken
it's very interesting it's very telling
that none of the demonstrations none of
the upheavals in the Arab world have
been about the Palestinians that is
extremely significant what they've been
about is local issues issues of
development education unemployment
freedom they are the issues about which
the un-arab human development report
reports like that has written very
widely about the failure of the
development model in the Middle East
more broadly you know if we look we can
see that what drives states in the
region to act for syphilis Lee let's
have a look at saudi arabia yeah they
put out a peace plan but it was a peace
plan that was designed so that they
wouldn't actually have to do anything it
was a diktat it was thrown out there may
be an advertisment or two in the
jerusalem post but that was it but when
they had to confront Iran things were
different vocal support for Israel
in the second lebanon war and recently
the use of Saudi troops in Bahrain so
it's clear that for another of America's
key allies in the region what really
moves them is the threat of Iran is the
overall strategic picture in which there
are allies of the United States Jordan
Egypt Israel Saudi Arabia and there are
those who seek to challenge the order
which is underwritten by the Americans
come us Hizbollah Iran and what troubles
America's allies primarily is that
balance of power doesn't mean that they
are unconcerned with the arab-israeli
issue but they look and we should look
at the arab-israeli issue as part of a
broader picture not the picture so when
it comes to the United States and it
having to decide what its policy
priorities in a region are the threat of
a nuclear Pakistan the threat of a
nuclear Iran the threat of losing a
country like Egypt which has been the
cornerstone along with Israel of the
pro-american balance of power in the
Levant in that in there in the
Mediterranean in that part of the Middle
East where else it's that cornerstone
was put in place in 1975 by Henry
Kissinger because Israel and Egypt are
the two strongest military powers they
both receive American arms and therefore
it's very difficult for them to go to
war against each other an extended way
and that power block creates a dynamic
which says in the Arab world you know
what you can't beat Israel militarily so
you have to either try and come to a
full peace agreement or manage things in
an acceptable way and that has been at
the cornerstone of the whole dynamic
underwriting every attempt to make peace
and that cornerstone now has a crack in
it it is shaking and that is very very
significant I'm not going to go into
what's going on in Egypt it's not my
expertise and I'm sure it's going to be
spoken about but if you want to
understand the peace process I've just
been informed hillel to speak about it
then when that foundation goes
everything else starts to shake
what are the implications of my analysis
for looking at negotiations and how and
how they're progressing I think that we
should think that it's not simply a
diplomatic and political game that's the
way we generally talk about the peace
process we talk about cant on yahoo
deliver can Abbas deliver what are their
positions are they close enough are they
not close up clearly those are very
important questions but we need to go
down to the foundations and we need to
say even if they were to reach certain
agreements can those agreements be
sustained in a way that a will last
between the parties and be will maintain
and reinforce the pro-american balance
of power in the region because if they
offer offer lots of opportunities to
forces that are against stability and
would like to overturn that then not
only will they overturn the pro-american
balance of power they will bring the
whole piece down and the particular
issue I'm thinking of is the one of the
Jordan Valley and the Jordan Valley in
Israeli strategic thinking for since the
six-day war has been thought of as
Israel's security border and that is the
massing of Israel's existential
nightmares the massing of Arab armies in
Jordan that would pose a threat because
without the West Bank Israelis is nine
to ten miles why did its narrowest point
and that concern meant that someone like
you it's cut Robin always said that the
Jordan Valley would be Israel security
border and there was an argument whether
a security border needs to have Israel
need to have sovereignty or doesn't need
am sovereignty but recently there's been
talk about international forces being
put in to the Jordan Valley as a
replacement for Israeli troops I think
it I think though what's happened in the
region should give us a great pause for
thought about whether that is a good
idea not only for Israel but actually
for everybody because if one looks at
what's happened in Lebanon with the
weakness of international forces
preventing the importation of missiles
if one looks what happens when
international forces are challenged the
world over if you look at what happens
in the former Yugoslavia they're not
willing to fight in a way that their
enemies are willing to fight they're not
prepared to lose people they're not
prepared to kill people to the same
degree of their enemies and therefore
the will and the political commitment I
think would not be there to withstand
efforts to infiltrate into the West Bank
radical forces missiles and the rest of
it in a way that would directly threaten
Israeli population centers and which
would of course of course mean an
Israeli respond to protect its citizens
so I think it is highly unwise to look
at the Jordan Valley and say yes an
international force can resolve this and
given that Abbas has at least publicly
stated that he will not accept Israeli
forces in the Jordan Valley and that he
would only accept an international force
I think that for this aside from all the
other reasons that my colleague aight i
mentioned about why and also professor
point about why a permanent status
agreement is not possible this is
another one that we should think of in a
underlying sense as opposed to a
political or diplomatic sense but as
I've said conflict resolution of
conflict management are two outer
boundaries between them are many options
and the problem or the issue if you like
is that there isn't an option of doing
nothing on the peace process not for
long because conflict management
requires at least the semblance of
conflict resolution it requires a peace
process because of vacuum has political
consequences and strategic consequences
when people are talking that creates a
political focus when they're not it
creates openings for people who'd like
to cause trouble and particularly at the
moment when one sees all this
instability going on although it would
be a mistake to say everything as I said
depends on what goes on between Israelis
and Palestinians it's important for
those who want to have a stable Middle
East which can move forward in a
positive direction to take away
from extremist cards that they could use
to stir things up and therefore I think
that there is nonetheless an American
interest in having a semblance of a
peace process which needs of course a
certain amount of credibility and if one
takes step back from the all-or-nothing
approach of permanent status then I
personally believe that that is if you
think of the peace process is a Venn
diagram a space where Israel's core
interests Palestinians core interests
those of a bus and fired and the
American core interest actually do
intersect now I'm not promising you
being the Middle East that this can
actually the intersection of interest
means everyone will be rational and
follow a solution but I think such an
intersection does exist and it exists on
a number of levels first of all we're
all on the same side in the broader
regional fight we none of us wish Iran
Hamas Hezbollah to get stronger so
keeping Hamas and Hezbollah and Iran
week and dealing with them is a
strategic interest of all concerned
second of all and Israel's core interest
if you read Netanyahu's speech that he
gave her the begging seductive very
carefully you'll see that the core
issues for him are Israeli security and
Israel's definition as a Jewish and
democratic state which translates into
the refugee question what was not a core
issue with settlements that's very
significant and he got a standing
ovation and there was silence in Israel
and we had a 10-month settlement freeze
there's a very interesting coalition of
people who are interested in an interim
agreement in Israel it ranges from yossi
beilin who is the godfather of the Oslo
process they're the maybe the main
advocate in Israel previously of a
permanent status agreement ranging
across the israeli center to shell morph
as the former chief of staff for number
two in Kadima including two of israel's
most renowned journalist you GRE and
irish of it across to the bete noire of
the world the Israeli Foreign Minister
Avigdor Lieberman
and although there are differences
between what they're talking about there
is some common parameters one is the
creation of a Palestinian state in
interim borders according to the second
stage of the roadmap we'd be talking I
imagine about 60 to 70 something percent
the barrier excluding the barrier and
and the Jordan Valley which would
provide something like ninety-eight
percent contiguity for Palestinian
citizens in the West Bank we were
talking about having to deal with the
status of around fifty thousand settlers
which is probably around half of what
would be have to be dealt with according
to the parameters that Professor Quan
referred to before in a permanent status
agreement and we would have a choice
about whether settlin settlements would
be taken down or whether they would be
transferred to Palestinian sovereignty
my senses the government would prefer
the latter I personally always conceived
of the peace process of the divorce
process and therefore would prefer the
former a clean line a clean break but of
course there are political
considerations but one shouldn't
belittle the fact that a center-right
government and has political capital and
legitimacy to do things that it would be
much more difficult for a center left or
left government to do and one only has
to think of the disengagement to be
reminded of that fact now of course
while there's broad support in the
Israeli side for an interim agreement
there's only one slight problem and that
is there's no support on the Palestinian
side for an interim agreement and Israel
and Palestinians actually have similar
concerns Israelis who are against an
interim agreement fear that Israel will
be giving up its cards which our
territory and therefore would be in a
weaker position in permanent status and
the Palestinians are concerned that an
interim agreement will be a final
agreement and they will get trapped into
that and they will not get what they
feel they deserve my own view is that
those two issues in a sense balance each
other out those concerns that have a
certain balance and that therefore they
that that needn't be essentially a
problem my sense is that the
conversations going on right now between
the Israeli government and Dennis Ross
are quite important
and that they may well be about this
interim idea and my sense is if that
Israel was to put on the table a
significant prospect which involve
dealing with a large amount of settlers
and settlements that the United States
would take this on board given that they
don't have good idea of what's going on
now and given that the alternative of a
Palestinian attempt to push through
through the General Assembly are
unilaterally the idea of passing state
in 67 borders with these Jerusalem would
be the equivalent of throwing the cards
in the air at a particular time when the
region is unstable and my sense is that
most countries would prefer not to do
that and therefore I do think that if
the Prime Minister does come out with an
initiative along the lines that I have
laid out that it could actually provide
a basis for conflict management at the
same time contributing in the longer
term to conflict resolution while at the
same time preserving and perhaps even
enhancing the pro-american balance of
power in the Middle East thank you very
much Jonathan yeah we start now the Q&A
period please if anybody has a question
there's a microphone here in the middle
goes there and I'll allow you to ask you
a question I thank you very much I have
a question Shane named Reinhold or yes I
know I think what you said the very last
point about the interim agreement I
think what's appealing about that is
that it gives the Palestinians cover
there's so much terrible incitement in
the media and everything against Israel
just awful awful things that it's sort
of they can turn to their people and say
look this isn't the hold is just in at
least try to make it a question ok yeah
do you agree with that basically that
it's it gives the Palestinians cover
will take a few questions and afterwards
will take around 0 NE sauce please
yeah can you identify stuff my name is
Kenneth the Alton I'd like to ask
everyone but Professor quant the brought
up the issue we're talking about
discussion of the arab-israeli peace
treaty and how important it is or isn't
while the world is burning my question
is can anyone objectively historically
do you politically strategically tell me
why it is important relevant immediate
and necessary for that issue to even be
on the international table now when
there are so many other things I create
the impasse or create the unlikelihood
of instead of where where does the
geopolitical strategic urgency exist for
us to talk about this if I could put it
in context one second I was at the
meeting of Jewish leaders with the
president few weeks ago I was present at
a sidebar conversation somebody said to
the President as he was walking out mr.
president you were very sincere but and
even if people don't agree with you what
you know we appreciate your being here
and he said what is it you don't agree
with and the answer was the settlements
why are you worrying about this when
Rome is burning why are you pushing them
nobody cares WikiLeaks tells us nobody
cares so why are you pushing it and he
said the Palestinians care even if
nobody else does and because he made it
clear in the meeting that he was going
to continue to push that issue
fizzle julie's I have two questions
relate version on the American role what
about the counter argument that the
Arabs are and the Palestinians and the
Israelis come closer to agreement when
we're not involved it with the exception
of Camp David which we can attribute to
Bill's presence that you know look at
Oslo taba that and the negotiations
between all-american and Abu Mazen it
looks like they come closest when we're
not in the room now that wouldn't
preclude the role that bill suggested of
our coming in as a guarantor and
sweetener at the end but I wonder if
perhaps we're an enabler in the bad
sense as well as good sense and the
related question historically is there
any time looking back when you either of
the any of you can say if the US had
done something different we might have
gotten an agreement okay the last one
for this will have another don't hi bill
is Yusef oh I'm a brightener bill
mentioned quite correctly that there
have been two Republican hopefuls so far
in Jerusalem probably more coming and
both of the Republican hopefuls have
made on they're both in Jerusalem and on
their return radically different
statements about their view of the
settlement and the peace process is the
view in Jerusalem do you think now
anybody looking beyond an Obama
administration to the possibility of a
future Republican administration where
these sorts of views may in fact be the
basis of US policy towards settlement ok
I'll panelist will answer I'll make
brief responses first of all about
interim agreement yes if the choice is
between the continuation of the status
quo or violence is always always better
to have an interim agreement there are
good
dressed for both sides to search for in
interim agreement providing that and we
had it in the past we had the huge
debate about these alternatives to
negotiations one strike comprehensive
agreement selling every issue or going
step by step which was the original
Kissinger Zion idea the problem with
step-by-step is that first of all you
are required to make concessions and
then and you start with the least
difficult issues so by the time you get
to the most difficult issues you run out
of concessions number two if you don't
see the end result of the process then
it's very difficult to move through the
stages so I think that interim agreement
right now would be feasible if indeed
the two sides can also agree about at
least the basic structure of the final
peace agreement otherwise I don't think
it might work why there is a
geopolitical urgency for peacemaking if
if the status quo is likely to produce
Wars and violence then it's always
better to engage in negotiations and
peacemaking usually sides to a conflict
enter negotiations after war if there is
a big danger or threat of a war or when
there is opportunity and it seems that
the Obama administration felt at the
beginning of his tenure at the White
House that there was a great opportunity
ain't danger together to reach a
comprehensive arab-israeli peace
agreement because of Iran Iran
represented a major threat so that the
sides would be more willing to negotiate
an agreement maybe this agreement will
also be supported by by the Arab states
now professor Gervais's point is very
interesting yes the two big initiatives
that in fact produced one could use the
peace agreement sadat visit to Jerusalem
and the the also process came from the
Middle East itself I once wrote that the
u.s. role in the process is function of
two things the level and scope of
differences between or among the sides
and then the question is always at what
point you come in in order to push for
in agreement if you know when you start
negotiations you go like this some of
the problems that Middle East where that
you start negotiations you go like this
and then you go like that then you go
like this never it never goes like your
digs like this and you end with a final
push into an agreement when the other
states is is here somewhere it's not
helpful but as we have seen with the
Camp David process and even with the
Oslo process when the answers can come
in at the end just you need just a
little push and you need guarantees and
you need commitments from the United
States to compensate for the concessions
that the two sides are unable to make
then I think the contribution of us
mediation is is enhanced now I don't
think that anybody in Israel things to
be out the post elections in the United
States Israel has had elections almost
every two years in the last decade or so
so the this the the time the time frame
is about two to two and two and a half
years no more than that but there is a
concern about the declining standing of
the United States and the Middle East
and maybe in the world because it seems
that Israel's ability to make
concessions for a genuine peace
agreement
depend on American strength and American
leadership and American commitments in
the Middle East and right now there are
many questions asked I think not only in
Israel but also in the whole region
where the United States is going will
the United States continue to be a world
leader can the United States be relied
upon for whatever commitments or all
guarantees that our essential needed to
reach to reach basically Thanks well
I'll just pick up a few of the questions
and a few things about them and maybe
reflect on a point or two from the
earlier conversation as well you know if
everybody were to agree Israelis and
Palestinians that an interim agreement
is the way to go I don't think there's a
principled American objection to steps
of that sort what I think does exist now
is there certain skepticism that it's
going to happen or that you get very
much in return for initiatives of that
sort so I don't think it's going to be
an american-led effort if Jonathan's
right that it's a great idea and there's
a overlapping space and will eventually
come to it the United States will not be
the party that vetoes it if the others
want it that I honestly think this is
used Goods people have talked about it
it's never happened it's built on a
model of confidence-building that little
steps lead you to be more courageous
about taking big steps and it honestly
it's not true it hasn't worked didn't
work in the 1990s when it was the
dominant paradigm parties as they got
closer to the hard decisions were
actually more distrustful than they had
been at the beginning so I think it's a
real hard sell first and foremost with
the Palestinians who are as we've all
noted a in a week situation oddly enough
the one party on the Palestinian side
that would be kind of open to it most of
you won't agree with this is probably
Hamas Hamas doesn't believe that a final
peace agreement between Israelis and
Palestinians is possible they do believe
that prolonged periods of kind of
tacit understandings might be possible
and if that's what an interim initiative
ends up looking like is this kind of a
tacit understanding for a period of time
they might be the ones who would not be
so much in opposition but but Abu Mazen
himself has said quite explicitly that
he's not going to be interested and he
may not be around for very much longer
in any case why do this at all I don't
think there is very much motivation
right now we've heard the reasons why in
earlier periods people thought it was
important and I think the president had
actually told this gentleman something
that shouldn't be ignored no this still
does matter for Palestinians and quite
frankly it still matters for Israelis at
this conflict be brought to an end also
I think I disagree a little bit with my
colleagues who have said that WikiLeaks
kind of proves that nobody in the Arab
world cares about the Palestinian issue
anymore we're talking about regimes who
are talking with Americans about very
specific issues we're not sampling
public opinion in Egypt or Jordan or
elsewhere were you to do so and people
have done it you you would find that
there's still quite a bit of concern and
if ordinary people didn't have it every
day they would see it on al-jazeera and
in all honesty that has an impact in the
Arab world so as Egypt becomes more
democratic don't think this issue
becomes less important it will become
part of the new Egyptian government's
foreign policy line that we've got to
get back to the RV's early peacemaking
because they will be reflecting more the
public sentiment at home I don't think
that means that suddenly things are
going to change but the issue is not
going to go away and I have a feeling
that a fair number of people who have
spoken would like to see it sort of
drift off into obscurity while we deal
with other issues but I don't think
that's going to happen bob jarvis raises
the interesting point of has the
American effort in sort of
counterproductive that is the parties do
better on their own
I'm probably a biased observer I was
involved in the egyptian-israeli thing
and I honestly don't believe that they
could have brought it to a conclusion in
1978-79 without the United States doing
a pretty intensive job of mediation and
if anybody wants the long version on
that I can refer them to what I've
written or I can have a side
conversation with you but that's just my
judgment about that moment Oslo was an
exception also note Oslo didn't work it
wasn't carried to a conclusion it was a
starting point but it never got very
much beyond and when the party's started
to try to implement Oslo they accepted
an American rule in trying to move it
forward where were the moments in
response to Bob Gervais's question when
the United States might have made a
difference I think that there were two
moments in the last 20 years when if the
United States had played its hand
differently we might have seen peace
agreements achieved at least on one
front if not more that was in the Rabine
1993 295 period and particularly on the
Syrian Israeli front after a beam had
made his decision and had communicated
to the united states that he would
accept the June 4th 1967 line Warren
Christopher hate to say anything bad
about somebody was just passed away but
he was not a very strategic thinker
about this this was a fairly significant
moment when an american-led initiative
to deal with Syria might have moved that
conflict very close to being susceptible
to resolution had that happened in
1994-95 there's a lot of ifs it also
would have changed the dynamic on the
palestinian-israeli relationship because
they would have then been the last party
out and all of our thoughts you know
playing for time and his duplicity
would have cost him an awful lot at that
point and I think you might have had one
of those rare moments when you would
have had a strong president leading with
a strong Israeli Prime Minister a strong
Syrian leader and yes our fought with
all of his weirdness was at that time a
strong political leader he could have
delivered so I look back at that period
say we never fully exploited the
potential that was given us by the fact
that we had this alignment of forces
that might have given us a chance to
play the brokers role effectively the
last chance and I really do think it's
the last one that is worth reflecting on
was early two thousand when Clinton once
again decided time is coming his passing
if I'm going to do anything to kind of
leave a legacy I've got to do it quickly
and once again he got remarkably close
on the Syrian Israeli front I mean I've
just finished writing something in
detail about this I think they had a
deal in the makings they didn't quite
have all the pieces but they were pretty
close and they screwed it up they
meaning Barack screwed it up Assad
screwed it up n clinton screwed it up at
clinton was was at fault in the way he
handled the last shepherdstown
negotiation and his summit meeting with
AUSA from then on I'm not sure there
have been good openings but those had
they been concluded at that time they
would have made a difference okay thank
you um the question of whether an
interim agreement gives Palestinians
cover I think as Professor Kwon said you
know they're not in favor right now I
think the thing that is good for them is
they don't you have to give anything
they you know they just get and although
they have to demonstrate is that it's
not the end so I think that you know
that's the advantage from their point of
view and and because I'm extraordinarily
skeptical that they can make the kind of
requirements that even an Olmec
government let alone a Nataniel
government can live with
I think it's the only option really
however unlikely or however to have a
while accepting that even though I think
it's in everyone's interest it's
probably less than fifty percent likely
to happen why why do we have to deal
with this well as i said i don't think
it is a key strategic priority for the
US but the US has to nonetheless deal
with it to prevent it becoming an
irritant in lots of other things but it
is very key for israel and for the
Palestinians and because i think
partition is ultimately a vital interest
of the state of israel anything that
moves us closer to that from an israeli
perspective as opposed to american
spective is a positive thing
particularly if it moves us closer in a
way without taking serious strategic
threats just political difficulties
would it make a difference what happens
when the u.s. is involved or not
involved I don't believe that the United
States could have done anything to make
an agreement happen when an agreement
didn't happen I think that the mantra of
All American Secretary of State's since
James Baker that we can't make peace for
the parties we can assist we can visit
is absolutely correct and it's just
wishful thinking otherwise look it does
however America makes a difference is no
doubt that America makes difference but
if you what happens is not so much that
you can help make peace but you can you
can prevent you can help prevent things
deteriorating you can you can make
differences I think going forward with
Camp David to when things were not
properly thought out or ready or ripe or
whatever you want to say was a mistake
it was a well-meaning mistake but it was
a mistake and it might have been wiser
to look for ways to prevent that I can't
guarantee you that the wouldn't have
been a second intifada but I think that
that it could have been it could have
made a difference sometimes it's better
to be more modest Republican Republican
statements look um
Israelis will be bemused by American
political leaders coming and saying
various things that talk to American
politics but not to Israeli political
realities it's not that you know the
evangelical right in the United States
is as important as some people say but
it is worth bearing in mind that there
are more evangelical Christians who
believe in the whole land of Israel than
there are Jews in the world so you know
the resonance of that particular message
is going to resonate better in the you
know in the South here than it is in
Jerusalem and that's something to bear
in mind in understanding how perhaps
Israelis look at it and and you know if
george w bush couldn't eat that much
into the american jewish vote I'm
skeptical that anyone else will be able
to unless Obama makes mistakes along the
lines that Jimmy Carter did it's really
it's up to the Democratic candidate to
lose the Jewish vote it's much more
difficult for the Republican candidate
to win it I don't think it's about trust
I don't think the reason that I thinking
that an interim agreement is a good idea
is not because i think that trust in it
builds trust it's because i think it
creates a situation on the ground where
Israelis Palestinians and American
allies are better off everyone gains
something and that that might actually
be create an environment where the very
fragile but nonetheless positive moves
taken by fired on the ground have a
chance of developing in a way that will
assist eventually Israeli person your
coexistence one of the phrases that
Tzipi Livni used I don't actually used
it publicly but she certainly used it
privately is there's nobody to give the
keys to and that is if from an Israeli
perspective and the consensus is real is
this that partition is a vital interests
of the state of israel if that's the
case the key issue for Israelis is can
we give someone the
without getting a missile on my house
and that's the issue for that's the
mainstream Israeli political issue it's
not about settlements although that is a
important issue in the negotiations but
that's the crux issue for Israelis and
if you create an interim period in which
Palestinian economy in the West Bank and
governance improve and Israeli security
improves and I'm being beyond optimistic
here then I think that that is a
positive foundation not for building
trust for some negotiate for some
agreement down line but for putting in
the deep type of strategic foundations
that can make that sort of thing stand
eventually thank you few more questions
Hillel fresh from besa um as you know um
people have spoken about a partition
between Israel and the Palestinians but
the only partition so far has been the
partition between the Palestinians
there's been a painter Palestinian
partition but no Israeli Palestinian
partition and given the durability of
political entities in the Middle East
more durable in fact than in Europe how
how does the peace process continue
given that there are two feudal
statelets one in Gaza and one in the
West Bank war of Judea and Samaria were
effectively in civil war and bloodshed
is only being prevented because Israel
holds the Negev please so just
successfully job lady does time favor
one side as opposed to the other and is
it possible that mutual exhaustion will
play a major role ultimately as it did
for example in Ireland my name is Gil
kulick and the question is stressed the
Israeli members of the panel I'm
wondering if you're at all concerned
about the impact that the occupation is
having on Israeli society there are many
of us who are quite
armed at the steady erosion of
democratic values the as manifested by
the number of bills before the Knesset
that would limit freedom of speech that
would punish dissent and so forth I
believe that this is an existential
threat to the Democratic Jewish state of
Israel I'm wondering whether either of
you agree that this should lend some
urgency to the need to reach an
agreement notwithstanding all of the
problems that you've enumerated okay
take first question was about the split
in the Palestinian community I think
this is the major obstacle to peace the
typical American approach to this
problem has been I've spoken to a number
of officials and even I think Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton said that once
there is an agreement between Israel and
the Palestinian Authority then it's
going to be some kind of a democratic
decision there going to be some kind of
an elections or referendum on on a
treaty and this will this will force so
to speak the issue and Hamas the second
and the second answer was that given
given a peace agreement then perhaps
Hamas and the Palestinian Fatah will
join the government will make a
government of national unity some people
suggest that this is what they are
working on right now a government of
national unity the problem with that
idea is that who is going to dominate
this government of national unity maybe
the US thinks it's going to be it's
going to be Fatah but Hamas is are the
ideas and how much is much stronger even
in the west bank then then Hamas because
of all kinds of reason
than the VA yes so so this is the I
think this is this is a major problem
that has that I don't know if there is a
solution to that but I think that this
is this is a major obstacle on the road
to a peace agreement one of the Israeli
concerns which jonathan made earlier is
if you have if you have a peace
agreement today in Israel were to
withdraw but more of the West Bank are
we going to see another version of Hamas
as Gaza there and how you can be sure
that this is not going to happen time
whose time every obviously both sides
think that time / place into their favor
because if this had not been the case we
might have seen more pressure to
negotiate and to reach an agreement some
people some some Palestinian suggest
that the two-state solution should be
abandoned and that the one-state
solution should be adopted counting on
the mog raphy and some kind of
developments maybe in the international
arena such as un recognition of a
Palestinian state within ninety seven
borders somehow will create conditions
on the ground that would be much more
favorable to their demands some Israelis
believe time works in their favor and
that eventually the Palestinians would
would reach a conclusion would conclude
that there is no way to impose their
demands on Israel and that somehow a
compromise is going to be reached so I
think this is another obstacle to
negotiations to resuming negotiations
right now the impact of the occupation
and Israeli society this has been a
highly exaggerated in Israel and abroad
it's being made by people who who are in
favor of peace now peace now now
obviously there are all kinds of
problems
I Gaza israel withdrew from gaza it
resumed from some parts of the West Bank
yeah yeah there are some some problems
that emerge from the need to establish
security in a West Bank and I think they
also emphasized Salomon's and occupation
have no idea what's going on in the
Middle East and do not understand the
reef forces that either block or promote
negotiations between the two sides on
the first question of how much of the
blockage in the peace process is due to
the fact that the Palestinians are
divided of course it makes it harder for
them to negotiate but quite frankly we
didn't see a big dynamic move toward
israeli-palestinian peace when the
Palestinians weren't so divided if you
go back to when the PLO was a more or
less unified movement the basic
substantive issues dividing Israelis and
Palestinians were still there Abu Mazen
spizz itions on most of these are no
different from more or less what our
efforts positions were on terms of the
67 borders East Jerusalem some limited
right of return rejecting Israeli troops
in the West Bank and so forth so that
didn't really change from say the early
1990s when Hamas was not a very big
figure to today when it it is a bigger
figure so yes it complicates the notion
of kind of getting a coherent
Palestinian voice into the negotiations
but I think it's less the determining
factor than has been implied by some of
the other speakers who does time favor
in this you know looking at this as an
outsider I I don't actually think that
time is on either side in the sense that
if we just sit back and let 10 or 15
years unfold let nature take its course
if we can imagine that happening that
one side will emerge saying WOW was
really worth it we're in great shape now
I think we're more likely to see 10 or
15 years from now something it looks
quite similar to what we have today now
if you think it's pretty good today
maybe it'll be okay then but certainly
for many Palestinians it's not very good
for some Israelis it's not very good for
the region as a whole it remains a kind
of irritant and I'm afraid that's that's
what time favorites is just more of the
same not that one side will give up this
is not the kind of conflict where one is
going to say oh my gosh we finally came
to our senses and realize we're on the
wrong side of history and we're going to
abandon our goals so I'm going to happen
Palestinians will never be strong enough
on their own to reverse the trends we're
talking about the one thing we can be
quite sure of as as time goes on the
settlement process which people again
have been saying isn't so important but
I can tell you it based on the past
every year there will be ten to fifteen
thousand more settlers living in the
West Bank so project that forward
another 20 years and you're going to
have another two to three hundred
thousand Israelis living in the West
Bank and it makes it almost
inconceivable at that point that what we
were told that for Netanyahu settlements
are not an issue well they may not be an
issue for him they're going to be for
Israeli society because you'll have you
know upwards to a million people living
beyond the old green line so time
changes some of the contours of the
conflict it doesn't solve the conflict
people talk about there will be a
two-state solution every one state
solution I think you're going to have a
an outcome with in the absence of a
political agreement in which Israel
remains the strongest party in its
immediate vicinity Gaza remains as it is
although Egypt may
open the Rafah crossing and make it a
little less constrained and the West
Bank will look pretty much as it is it a
lot of the young generation will leave
because it's not a very viable place to
you know set up businesses and razor
your families and that in the immediate
surrounding areas particularly in
Lebanon there will be a spillover effect
because there are lots of Palestinians
there and you're the kind of problems we
see now that stem from this unresolved
conflict will still be there in the rest
of the region Israel will have no
regional partners of significance Egypt
will not be a really I don't think
they'll go back on their peace but I
think it'll be an even colder peace than
it is now Iran unless something dramatic
happens is going to be an adversary and
perhaps a more dangerous adversary and
the way things are going now turkey
which five years ago had pretty good
relations with Israel is also going to
be a rather cool standoffish party in
the region so I'm afraid I see a Middle
East emerging in which we actually have
three centers of power with ambitions in
the region Iran Egypt a new Egypt and
Turkey Israel locked into its conflicts
in its immediate environment but with no
good relations with anyone else in the
region and the United States which is
getting fed up with the region will
concentrate on the oil issue because
it's strategically important and
therefore will focus on security access
to the Gulf region but will cease to
have the ambition of remaking the Middle
East the way George W Bush I think
mistakenly did thinking that the United
States is so strong that it can remake
the Middle East to suit itself that over
reach in the bush period is going to
lead to a
this engagement now ask yourself how
many Americans today are concerned about
Iraq where we spent a trillion dollars
and still have 50,000 troops left people
just want out I'm not saying that's a
wise policy but we are going to be out
of Iraq Afghanistan similarly we went
into Afghanistan for reasons of national
interest people are losing interest and
I think we will be out of Afghanistan
within five years if not sooner so the
United States is I think in retreat
there are reasons for that an ambitious
foreign policy is expensive and as
people keep reminding us we're kind of
broke these days so you're going to see
a lot of hesitation even under a future
Republican president say let's go in and
remake Iran let's go in and remake Syria
I think for the foreseeable future
United States is going to limit its
foreign policy goals to things that are
truly high priority or not very
expensive and that probably means we are
going to be a bit more distant in our
relations with the Middle East than some
of you might like but I think it's I
think it's happening and so time is
going to affect American involvement in
the Middle East I think we're a
retreating power nobody else is going to
step in and take over that role but
within the region i do think they're
going to be three significant powers
that try to shape the arena and there
will be a lot of competition over
countries like Syria and Iraq Jordan and
the Gulf region and that's where the
great game is going to play itself out
and in that region Israel's going to be
behind its barrier and with its
deterrent capabilities but without
allies in the region um okay Hamas as I
said I think that got part of the whole
point of an interim thing is that it
doesn't have the problem that you have
to deal with a unified Palestinian
government because it's only an interim
agreement to do with the West Bank but I
do feel that over time if that
experiment was to succeed that that
would would help I mean it could take a
very long time
it took a very long time for West
Germany to be the successful experiment
and these Germany to collapse time is is
a complicated thing I think professor
Kwon said nearly everything that i would
say on the subject he said that i would
say that for israel it I mean Ephraim
thinks that time is on Israel side I'm
kind of more of a double pessimist in
that I think that time is not on Israel
side particularly on the issue of
settlements partition that we spoke
about on the other hand it's not as if
there is a clear-cut way of breaking out
of that there might be better ways of
managing it and minimizing its effect
which is what I've suggested and and
this goes to the last point about the
effect of the occupation on Israeli
society when you use the term the
occupation you imply that if Israel
suddenly was not occupying that all
these problems would go away and since I
fundamentally disagree with that I think
that's funded fundamentally mistaken
perception the problem is the conflict
and what the conflict does to Israeli
society the reason for the trends in
Israeli society is because of what's
happened in the last ten years in the
conflict the collapse of the peace
process the increasing identification of
Israeli Arabs with Hamas and Hizbollah
not the majority but some of the
statements of the leaders and some of
the things that went on in the wars
including azmi Bashara for you know
former member of parliament he's had to
leave the country because otherwise
we'll be tried for treason all sorts of
things like that it's not like somehow
Israel is the key actor and everything
the whole rest of the conflict depends
exactly on what we do or we don't do of
course depends partly on what we do so i
mean i think you're right i think one of
the things that's happening in Israeli
society is a the heightened threat
perception is causing people to be
threatened feel threatened more and
that's closing down some of the civic
space in a variety of ways but it comes
from fears and threats and it's not
unique to Israel if one looks
for some interesting article academic
articles have been written about you
know levels of insecurity and democracy
and one of the reasons that Britain and
America are stable democracies is
because they were safe for a very long
time not the only reason but it took one
of the main things away so I think that
that we have a definite dilemma problem
issue but but unfortunately we can't
just wave a wand and it will go away
it's not quite as simple as that okay I
think we had enough for spiritual food
and we have a break 15 minutes would be
back